video of a deadly accident obtained
exclusively by cbs
news is raising safety questions about a
popular luxury suv
the driver's family is suing claiming
the roll-away accident happened because
the suv's dial gear shifter
appeared to be in park when it was not
this family is not alone but the
automaker denies their claims and blames
operator error chris van cleave has the
story
and we warn you some of the images
you're about to see are very hard to
watch
it's shocking video two families hope
can save lives
41 year old shoddy farhat was getting
out of her 2017 range rover suv
when it started rolling pulling her
underneath the los angeles mother of two
made it to her feet before collapsing
she died days later i lost the love of
my life i lost my best friend
her husband michael is now raising their
girls alone i can't make sense of it i
don't understand why this had to happen
to us it's just so preventable
in his lawsuit against jaguar land rover
farhat blames what he calls
the defective gear selector in their
range rover which uses a dial like this
one
instead of a stick to change gears did
she complain about it at all
she complained about it a lot i can't
tell if it's in park i can't tell if
it's in reverse i can't tell if it's in
drive
his lawsuit cites this 2013 land rover
special service message to dealers
warning about concern with the gear
shift module becoming
stuck in position or has erratic or
intermittent operation
it recommended repairs and these company
documents from 2017
indicating the automaker was aware of
hundreds of potential
unintended roll away complaints in
vehicles with a dial shifter
including 28 in the range rover gina
wore
says it happened to her last month with
her four-year-old son
in the car i believe i put the car into
park got out the car
and my car started reversing towards me
it knocked me down
her lawsuit claims the suv ran over her
right hand requiring reconstructive
surgery
it was horrific it was a nightmare that
is forever haunting me which i'm so
grateful to be alive
the national highway traffic safety
administration spent nearly four years
investigating reports of unintended
rollaways involving jaguar land rover
vehicles with a dial shifter
in august nitsa closed its probe saying
it has not identified any mechanical or
electronic faults
causing the vehicle to shift out of park
and blamed operator error
isn't it sort of on the driver to put
the car into park before you get out of
it sure
but drivers are confused and
land rover knows that drivers are
confused and this is unfortunately
the inevitable result of what happens
when
people think that the car is in park and
it's not following the 2016 death of
star trek actor anton yelchin in a
suspected rollaway incident involving
his jeep grand cherokee with a recalled
shifter
many car makers added safeguards on new
vehicles to prevent such an incident
including
automatically shifting to park jake
fisher from consumer reports
as soon as i open that door car hasn't
rolled at all it's automatically
gone to park in 2017 consumer reports
started requiring roll away protection
for cars to earn top marks
if you get in the habit of putting the
parking brake on which a lot of people
don't do
that could absolutely prevent the car
from rolling land rover added the roll
away protection in 2018
to hybrid range rovers only i want to
get it out there that there is a problem
with this car
i don't want anyone else to go through
this again nitsa documents say if a
driver
opens the door of a range rover when it
is not in park an audible alert sounds
and a message flashes on the dashboard
the regulator says it is aware of these
two incidents and continues to monitor
the situation
jaguar land rover declined comments
citing pending litigation
but says it is committed to safety and
saddened to hear of these incidents
for cbs this morning chris van cleave
washington
you know what i take away from that is
what that one gentleman said about
putting the parking brake on
you never think about that but what a
simple solution of just getting in the
car and doing that
and we've rented cars that have those
types of shifters and
yeah it's a little confusing when you're
trying to figure out whether it's in
drive or neutral or in fact i remember
once i was driving and i actually
kept stepping on the accelerator i'm
just glad we brought attention to it
yeah i think you have a lot of people
out there who
remember having those issues or at least
now there's going to be more
paid to it as well chris van cleeve
transportation correspondent cbs news we
appreciate it chris thank you